multiply and divide terms the keeping
key really is remember your index don't
remember your next low so that's just a
bit of a mental tag for you if you kind
of like wait what is this
you had a whole topic on indices in you
9 and 10 this is what we're kind of
calling back okay so let's cut do a few
examples very briefly let me just pull
these up okay
oh yeah so Gretchen that cost every
second letter as opposed to do every
that's really inconvenient at the same I
don't mind if you start at a or b it's
really funny because um geniuses tend to
pay for that's awesome I can skip the
whole question of course you end up
doing the same number of questions
because give you heart that's the
important thing
one of the things you will notice is
that generally speaking most textbooks
give you a stupid number of questions
more than you possibly need so I sort of
want to get on with this especially
being at you know notice of this this is
like stuff already addressed I just want
you to remember the other advantage of
this is that when you want to review
like you come back in my three four
weeks time like I remember this stuff
you don't need to like ask for a photo
shoot or something that you just do the
other questions the ones you didn't do
before so it's a pretty simple sort
strategy started a see okay let's have a
go at this there so the first thing I
want to notice is I just got two terms
I'm multiplying them to get up please
note you should make a big deal out of
my exes they look like that you might
like to draw your exes like this the one
thing you cannot draw your exes like is
that and I hope that the reason for that
is pretty clear
okay so be nice and unambiguous what I
deal with two different positives right
we want to deal with the numbers and now
we want to deal with the exit okay now
we have to name sellers and I love you
to write them down underneath a point so
firstly the numbers have the property
attached to the axis we call them the
coefficients you might have heard that
word before coefficients there the
numbers attached at the front then of
course you've got the exes and we've got
different names for those the most
common one that you come up with
you definitely know this is perennials
but they often also called variables I'm
going to put a question mark on that one
because there's not always variables
sometimes it's actually just a number
for instance there's a video-based that
we use this symbol for right that's a
hundred or two kinda
it's a printing rule but it's not
variable like it's one number and
everyone agrees that it's okay so that's
why I'm putting that little question
mark there but I want you to clue me in
sometimes they'll use that word and this
is what they refer to
so the reason I've highlighted that
there's two of them is because we want
to do them in turn coefficients are just
by convention we put them out first
you've got three there that one's
obvious this one's not so obvious this
is a number hanging in there
what's the number that's not written
it's a one right so I've got negative
one and three maybe one times three of
course is so I've dealt with the
coefficients naturally if I had more
numbers along and multiplied by another
term I just string along all of those
deal with the coefficients situated and
now I feel with those I'll move on to my
pronumerals
go next square here and the next is
thinking back to your index laws what
happens when you multiply numbers you're
gonna save X you add the indices right
so got a cheeky and again I'm gonna
index hiding there right just Adam
walking next year not with say X cute
now that fish okay not complicated
multiplication is very very coveted
multiplication let's move on to a
division example make this one a little
more involved shown
okay so here's our division now you
might find it a bit easier for yourself
if you pop this in as a fraction because
then you can do you can France a lot
easy to factor everything so I'm gonna
write that like so nothing's changed
nothing's changed it just makes a bit
simpler to compare the terms that are
interested in so again just like before
coefficients been proven you are seven
to fourteen and I want to suggest what
we can do with that good I'm gonna get
to where am I gonna get it to it just
don't use the right word I'm gonna get
it on there to nominate our right these
seven cancels with this at least moving
to that's good again I've got these
kinds of things happening here and this
is a perfect time to explain why when
I'm dividing because the opposite of
Alton what I do with the indices what's
the index law that comes with that I
subtract right now to make it obvious
why I take away you can see what is M
Squared like it's an abbreviation it's
an abbreviation for what and time same
very good I'm just kind of like that
okay and you can see obviously right
when you do the same canceling can you
did before that this time for that
pretty rolls one any cancels here one
cancels here right so you get that foo
bar with that one now I've got um a
couple of ways that I can now wrap my
answer
the first thing is I'll just leave it as
a fraction so that's one over to the
question is that asking me to but I am
going to the question began without
fractions right so being it at to begin
without fractions I'm not going to leave
my answer in a friend so how would I
write this without fractions again this
is a bit trickier
so you're put to the okay so everything
on this denominator right and I do put
everything to be a power of minus 1 why
don't do that this is about division
right so if I just thought about this
without doing it as a fraction right
I'll just put it down parallel here
unless you 7/14 just gonna be hard but
when you deal with these powers
you told me to subtract the power this
division happening keep fighting do you
see why you end up with a minus 1
you've got 110 away - are you seeing how
it's coming in so that's n to the power
4 minus 1 which is the same as able to
bottom the way I remember it is you
cross the line you change the sign okay
so when you have something on the bottom
here that's the same as a negative index
okay so either of those this guy yeah
they're all the same answer and they
simplify this far as it possibly can
with cancel dot everything really kind
of depends on how the question gets
handed to you how you answer back okay I
think probably this might be the best
one because this